السبيل والمحتاج والاف الاسر العفيفه
يتجمعون هنا في المكان نفسه والوقت ذاته
من كل عام مشهد مات تقليدا اصيلا في رمضان
فيه موائد الرحمن تستقبل الصائمين وتقدم
لهم وجبات الافطار بحب لا يقابل الا
بالكثير من الحب ودعوه من القلب نقوم على
خدمه حوالي 3500 صائم يوميا بقوم على
خدمتهم حوالي 80 متطوع بالاضافه الى الى
موظفي الاتكيه وهاي حاله تفاعليه جميله
والمتطوعين بصراحه في عنا ضغط كبير يعني
من المتطوعين اللي هو صار التطوع بين
موائد
تقليد يعني من تقاليد رمضان بالنسبه لهم
زي الفانوس سنوات طويله مرت وتكيه ام علي
تعمل على خدمه الصائمين عمل وجد به
المتطوعون اسمى اهدافهم حتى استمر الكثير
منهم بتحضير الطعام وتقديمه في تكيه ام
علي لاكثر من عشر سنوات كل اشي بتقدمه هون
وحتى بتشوف الناس بتكون مبسوطه وانت لما
تقدمي لهم اشي بتكون يعني في
ايجابي منك ومنهم اكيد شعور بالفرح
انه الاقل حظا والناس المحتاجين اكيد شعور
بالعطاء والعطاء ما له حدود اغتنام وشهري
رمضان في عمل الخير له وجه اخر هنا فتحت
عنوان سبيل صويلح يحضر مجموعه من الشباب
وجبات الافطار للعوائل العفيفه كما يقومون
بالبحث عن اي محتاج تعفف عن السؤال نقوم
بتوزيع ما لا يقل عن 100 صدر يوميا ويصل
العدد في بعض الايام الى 130 140 صدر
يوميا بفضل الله تعالى
نستهدف من يعني عملنا بفضل الله تعالى
الاخوه الذين يستحقون عملنا في هذا الشهر
المبارك وما وضع اقتصادي صعب وسوء احوال
الكثير من المواطنين تقدم هذه المبادرات
الرمضانيه جل ما يحتاجه كثيرون في شهر شرع
ابوابه لاعمال الخير سها جميل العربيه
عمان